Summerjam kommt zu klicksum und sein
neues Album hat einen vielversprechenden
Titel Sucuk und Champagner und da haben
er und wir uns gedacht hey das ist doch
perfekt für Chaos kochen und auf
hiphop.de gibt es deshalb ein Video wo
er euch auffordert eure Rezepte
einzureichen Link jetzt hier im Video
und unten im Info Text und ansonsten
erwarten wir natürlich wieder kreative
lustige spannende interessante Fragen an
ihn am besten hier als Videoantwort
unter dem Video posten oder auch in den
Kommentaren da könnte auch eure Meinung
sagen oder sonst was wir werden im
Community Video darauf eingehen wir sind
also schwer gespannt haut rein und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt dran